la semaine internationale de
l'agriculture c'est aussi la grande
bouffe car les milieux visiteur s'arrête
longuement devant les pavillons des
provinces françaises
pourtant les nombreuses spécialités
nationales que c'est bon tout ça surtout
quand c'est gratuit
en ce début des années 70 le salon de
l'agriculture à paris devient le rendez
vous incontournable des amateurs de
bonne chère et il y a de quoi faire
parfois on goûte sans même savoir ce que
c'est sa sensationnelle cette faute et
j'ai pas du fichier alliant
j'ai sérieusement beauté saucisse
fromage schouppe route
cette dégustation donne soif
heureusement au salon de l'agriculture
on y boit beaucoup et de tout des vins
bien sûr mais pas seulement
tous les alcools y passe sans oublier la
bière et le site
mais il arrive que le pique assiette
anonyme soit parfois confrontés à plus
fort que lui dans les années 90 il doit
se frotter aux meilleurs d'entre eux le
président chirac
excellent un cocktail de la glace et à
la fraise un morceau de pour l'évêque où
l'on des jambons de sa voix sur le pouce
il s'agit de faire plaisir à tous et
voilà admirer ce savoir faire
mais pour certains le savoir-faire
manque de savoir vivre alors au cours
des années 2000 certains producteurs
crack fatigués de voir toujours les
mêmes devant leur stand les huîtres
ayasse ça doit faire mal
enfin rassurez vous ce genre d'accident
est exceptionnel surtout si vous suivez
la méthode des vrais professionnels dans
sa catégorie
bruno est un champion du monde un pique
assiette professionnels
au salon de l'agriculture il est
méthodique il s'invite à tous les stands
des régions alors que vous ayez l'âme
d'un compétiteur ou plutôt celle d'un
simple participant on vous souhaite un
bon appétit
vous en aurez bien besoin allez en gros
de la petite 106 avait pas grossman est
bonne
[Musique]